hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be Mike game thrones episode for Q&A
video just careful for spoilers if you
haven't seen the episode yet all kinds
of awesome stuff we have to talk about
Snowbowl unburnt Daenerys one of the
coolest things that happened after last
night's episode was everyone was like
wow you know the CG during that fire
scene did look kind of weird but Emilia
Clarke came forward was like nope it me
that's definitely my naked body
she actually clarified that the people
like the the outlets in the previous
years that have been reporting that she
had a version of a no nudity clause was
misreported so apparently Emilia Clarke
totally down for doing nude scenes as
long as it forwards the story so I know
there's a lot of people wondering you
know why she looks a little bit
different this season than she has in
previous seasons you have to remember
that this is season 6 of the show so all
the actors have been working on this for
almost seven years look at little brand
in the pilot episode look how young he
looks now look at him in season six you
kind of understand why she didn't come
forward before this to explain
everything because it would have
completely spoiled this big moment at
the end of the episode here we go the
question time this dobersen Daenerys
sunburned so whitley padilla asks even
if she's immune to fire she's still as
fixie ate from lack of oxygen but who
cares it was cool I think that's kind of
the intention that the logic might be a
little bit bendy in the way it works out
but they wanted to have a sequel to that
unburnt moment from the end of season
one but I think even if you're
completely spellbound by beautiful
Emilia Clarke here you're still thinking
about her hatching the Dragons and
that's kind of the intention this really
big power play so you kind of wave your
hand at the logic a little bit and you
understand that they're trying to imply
that some magic is in play even if
they're changing some of the
interpretation of how that works from
the books the other really important
thing that's going on here is the
Dothraki are swearing fealty to her just
like in awe of her power but during
season one before she hatched the
Dragons before she became tener
sunburned she has three people to become
her blood riders they refused her this
was after a Khal Drogo had died but then
after she became denier sunburn they
were like oh my god you're amazing we
will totally be your blood riders so the
same thing will probably happen after
this episode next question I manifest if
the Tyrells have the second largest army
in Westeros who has the largest well
technically it's the westerland's so
that'd be the Lannisters they can raise
about
50,000 people in the books but I think
the TV show might be shrinking those
numbers a little bit in the region the
books is a little bit different so we're
already a little off-book here they say
they can raise between 80 and a hundred
thousand soldiers so I guess in terms of
TV show army size we're gonna have to
wait to see how it plays out because
technically the reach should have the
largest standing army but on the TV show
that might be the Lannisters in
combination with the Crown lands so it's
probably best just to ignore book army
size when you're thinking about TV show
army size because even the Bolton's
having five thousand men sounds like
it's been shrunk quite a bit the Vale
for instance is supposed to have 45,000
men
so imagine 45,000 men going after five
thousand it'd be ridiculous so I don't
know if that's gonna play out that way
on the TV show I'll be interested to see
how big the night's king army is though
because a lot of people are like aren't
sar supposed to be hundreds of thousands
of wildlings but you have to remember
that the night's king took the majority
of those people at hardhome
and turn them into whites next question
game of Leon's asks why is it called
pink even though it's not pink you're
talking about the pink letter so it's
called pink because the colour of the
wax it's supposed to look pink even
though it looks kind of red on the TV
show the other name for it in the books
is the bastard letter so you could call
it the bastard letter you'd call it the
pink letter but the big question in the
books was who actually wrote it did
Ramsay write it did mance rayder
secretly write at forging Ramsay's name
trying to get Jon Snow to march south so
there's a lot more little fingerstyle
plotting and scheming pitting people
against each other in the books next
question Jonathan asks in the episode 5
preview the night's king looks directly
at brand can Brandt actually teleport
well the the powers of bran are a little
fuzzy on the TV show no I don't think
that he can actually teleport though I
don't think that he can physically
teleport his body around he can teleport
his consciousness but as this is
happening like you see Meera trying to
shake him awake like please wake up
brand so as he's free to move about in
astral form his body is very vulnerable
next question shamil asks is it just me
or season 6 all about girl power well I
I know I know what you're talking about
what I think is going on though is it's
more of destruction of the patriarchy we
talked about it a little after the umber
betrayal like you have all these young
Lords - posing
their fathers killing their fathers in
the case of Ramsey destroying some of
the traditions that came before like
Daenerys destroying the tradition of
slavery from marine people are really
freaked out about that but you can see
that it's more of a positive tale in the
case of Daenerys searches the other side
of that she's destroying the patriarchy
she's destroying the small Council but
that might lead to something very
terrible so it's not quite as positive
as what Daenerys is doing and destroying
the patriarchy of slavers Bay which also
have Sansa up in the north who's trying
to destroy Ramsay who even though he has
destroyed his father and doesn't really
care about his traditions seems like
he's gonna be every bit as terrible as
his father was so sonses storyline is
all about destroying that so I wouldn't
say that season six is so much about
girl power like look at all these
powerful women as it is about destroying
the patriarchy of the world but have
some fun with thinking about how that
figures into your ideas of what the
endgame should be what you know for
season eight endgame next question guy
asks why is Littlefinger wanting to team
the Vale up with the starch to take down
the Bolton's how does this help
Littlefinger well I think it doesn't so
much directly benefit him as it puts
someone in power that he knows he has a
fairly good relationship with although I
do think there's going to be a reckoning
with respect to Sansa the funny thing
about Littlefinger is that the actor who
plays him says that he feels like his
character wants to atone for what
happened to Sansa that he didn't
understand how bad Ramsay was even
though in the books Littlefinger sounds
like he's a very smart person
so TV show Littlefinger does feel very
bad about what happened to Santa he's
trying to make amends part of the fun
this season of Santa's rise to power
we'll be seeing how she deals with him
when they meet again but I think a lot
of this alliance that he's trying to
form is in his own self-interest look at
the influence that he has over sweet
Robin he will he'll do anything he says
should we throw him through the moon
door so Littlefinger is too sweet Robin
as Cersei is to Tom and Tommen would
probably do anything to protect his
mother
so Littlefinger wants to maintain that
relationship and install someone in a
position of power who also likes him so
I think endgame what he's hoping is is
that he can marry Sansa to sweet Robin
so he might feel like he would have
control
over the largest standing army in
Westeros in that case if he has the
combined forces of the Vale and the
north but that is all dependent on Sansa
not hanging him from a tree the first
chance she gets
next question Stan asks what do you
think about the theory that the high
Sparrow is really Howland Reed I I've
never really bought into this theory
before and I don't think there's any
evidence based on the way the TV shows
using him that supports it either the TV
shows really presenting him as this
figure that Cersei cannot influence with
any of the things she would normally use
she can't use her body because he
doesn't seem to care about that she
can't use her money her Lannister gold
because he doesn't care about that
either so I think the TV shows just
trying to tell you that he's so
terrifying because there's nothing that
Cersei has that he wants next question
mark asks I wish they wouldn't stop at
Season eight
I mean they've already deviated from the
book so they can make stuff up and have
more seasons well I think mines they're
like you know don't go too far off book
but don't stop doing stuff there's a lot
of stuff that cut out but I think what
the TV show is doing is trying to be
true to Martin's original plan for the
story the original Song of Ice and Fire
story was only supposed to be three
books but there are a lot of twists that
cause Martin to expand that into what is
now seven novels so that's why when a
lot of people point to like Daenerys and
marine they call that filler story in
the books because Martin was stalling
for time trying to explain this big jump
in time for bran to learn about being a
green seer for Arya to learn about being
a faceless man so it sounds like based
on Martin's original outlines season 5
of Daenerys wouldn't have happened at
all after season 4 when she wrote into
marine in the Masters as they said in
this last episode we offered her ships
to sail to Westeros she would have just
taken all her people in sail to Westeros
and we would be happening our war for
the dawn right now so in a roundabout
way you could say that the TV show has
already expanded but I mean obviously
it's going based on the stuff that
Martin actually ended up writing so I
think everybody's in favor of there not
being filler it's really just the hard
out date that everybody's freaked out
about now the idea that season 8 would
be the last season and currently the
actors are only signed through season 7
so they still have to figure out season
8 because it sounds like what they might
end up doing is the Breaking Bad Mad Men
thing where they break the final season
into two separate seasons so that they
can a more time
the costs across two years just because
they're worried about the added cost of
all the extra special effects that
they're doing now that they weren't
doing before
next question rec asks do you think
George R Martin feels any pressure from
the show and he'd rather the show
continued to spin off on their own or do
you think he's working with him to keep
the main plots in line well he's
actually not doing any work on Game of
Thrones now he didn't write any scripts
for last season or this season so that
he can finish his books there they
really are diverging quite a bit and he
just posted a sample chapter people are
treating it like a really big deal but
he posts new sample chapters every year
it's just a new area and Martel chapter
and a lot of people felt like it was in
response to the lack of a dorrance
storyline this season so I think it's a
bit of a love-hate relationship where
he's really happy to see his work
happening on screen like he's really
happy that the series is getting made
but every once in a while he disagrees
with some of the story choices that they
make just like any author would next
question Aaron asks does Melisandre
actually saying that John is the prince
who's promised change anything not not
necessarily but remember the show tries
to be very literal very upfront about
the way it's teasing you a thing if
you're part of the cult that believes R
plus L equals J which I'm also a big
part of then you probably thought that
he was the prince who was promised
anyway but I think lines of dialogue
like that little teasers that they slip
in or more to lead the audience along
most of the people that watch the TV
show you know probably don't get too
hardcore into theories or maybe they
haven't read all the books so the TV
show has to explain everything that it's
going to pay off so I think this is just
more setup for the Tower of joy payoff
the R + L equals J the idea that he's a
really important figure in the war for
the dawn just like Daenerys unburnt is a
really important figure even though the
book explanation for both of these
characters and the prophecy of the
prince was promised is vastly more
complicated and open to interpretation
thank you everybody for so many
questions these are always a ton of fun
to do just remember that the TV show is
kind of like a Cliff's Notes for the
books so any explanation that you get
from the books will be vastly more
complex so even if you aren't now I
definitely recommend at some point you
try to read the books if you're not a
big reader the audiobooks are fun to
listen to I'm not a big fan of the
narrator but it is a really good
alternative if you want the book
experience but giveaway time
congratulations to this week's giveaway
winner and
of sarcasm human a $20 Amazon gift card
just be sure to private message me on
the back end of my channel so I can get
your contact details that's just on the
about page so what's gonna happen next
is there's big battle royale on the
flash tonight but I've already got a
couple ideas for my next game of Thrones
bonus video so that should post by the
end of this week why you guys wait for
that video to post you can click here
for my episode 4 video and you can click
here for the R + L equals J refresher
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight